[Musique]
la parole est à madame la présidente
eliane assassi pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et que le jce madame
la présidente vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mes chers collègues le
travailleur alerte immédiatement
l'employeur de toute situation de
travail dont il a un motif raisonnable
de penser qu'elle présente un danger
grave et imminent pour sa vie ou sa
santé ainsi que toute défectuosité qu'il
constate dans les systèmes de protection
il peut se retirer d'une telle situation
c'est la définition exacte du droit de
retrait droit reconnu par le code du
travail dans son article 41 31-1 et
c'est précisément ce qu'ont fait valoir
les cheminots suite à l'accident
ferroviaire du 16 octobre dernier
survenu l'avant veille des congés
scolaires pour rappel un autorail ter a
percuté un convoi routier faisant 11
blessés
cet accident grave qui aurait pu l'être
davantage sans l'esprit de
responsabilité exemplaire du conducteur
pourtant blessé a déclenché le droit de
retrait de 17 mille cheminots sur les 23
1000 conducteurs et contrôleurs soit +2
73%
ces agents ont considéré que les
conditions de sécurité n'étaient pas ou
plus assurée ni le gouvernement ni
l'entreprise n'ont répondu à ses
inquiétudes légitimes préférant par un
écran de fumée relancer un énième débat
sur le droit de grève
votre gouvernement n'a pas eu de mots
assez durs grève sauvage qui mérite des
poursuites judiciaires selon vous
mouvement social choquant selon la
ministre des transports
une grève injustifiée et illégale selon
le président de la sncf
la pédagogie de la répétition peut avoir
des vertus mais elle les perd
quand il s'agit d'asséner des
contrevérités au mépris de l'avis rendu
par l'inspection du travail qui a
considéré que le droit de retrait était
caractérisée justifier tout en rappelant
que l' entrave au droit de retrait
constituée elle même un délice qui
semble déplaire à madame la ministre du
travail
j'ai une question simple ce premier
ministre en tant qu actionnaire unique
de la sncf
que répondez-vous aux inspecteurs du
travail qui recommande le retour des
contrôleurs dans les trains dans
l'attenté d'une évaluation complète des
risques pour vous répondre la parole et
à monsieur le premier ministre monsieur
le premier ministre monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
madame la présidente vous m'interrogez
sur sept ce mouvement cette perturbation
très forte
cet accident qui sont intervenus à la
fin de la semaine dernière et pendant
tout le week end et qui ont à la fois
suscité l'interrogation et l'inquiétude
d'un certain nombre d'agents de la sncf
sur les conditions de sécurité et qui
ont également suscité un très grand
mécontentement et une très grande
incompréhension de la part d'usagers de
la sncf qui un jour de grand départ se
sont trouvés sans aucune information
sans aucune prise en compte des
problèmes parfois compliqué qui leur
étaient posées par ce mouvement et par
cette décision qui n'avait pas été
annoncée et je vous ne les avez pas
évoquer madame la présidente mais je
sais qu'au fond de vous-même vous pensez
également à eux à tous ses usagers qui
ont subi des désagréments et je vais
vous dire
[Applaudissements]
je je vais vous dire madame la
présidente je vous dire madame la
présidente que la question de la
sécurité est prise au sérieux par les
agents de la sncf les cheminots en
général bien entendu par l'entreprise
dans son ensemble direction comprise par
tout le monde y est que d'ailleurs dès
que la nouvelle de l'accident est
intervenu le gouvernement l'entreprise
et le gouvernement ont pris les
décisions qui doivent être prises c'est
à dire un audit interne la saisine du
bureau enquête accident transport
terrestre de façon à savoir exactement
ce qui s'était passé quelles procédures
ont été mises en oeuvre ou pas mises en
oeuvre
est ce qu'il faut en tirer comme
conclusion pour améliorer le niveau de
sécurité par la suite c'est ce qui se
passe à chaque fois vous le savez
parfaitement
c'est ce qui a été fait parce qu'on ne
transige pas avec la sécurité et parce
que chaque incident est une façon
d'apprendre et d'éviter soit qu'ils
puissent se reproduire soit d'autre type
de problème qui n'avait pas été pensé ça
a été fait comme ce sera
systématiquement fait à la suite de cet
accident
vous l'avez dit prêt de plus de 15000
conducteur les personnels de la sncf ont
fait valoir ce que le droit prévoit sous
le terme de droit de retrait ils se
trouvent
madame la présidente que nous n'avons
pas la même appréciation de la façon
dont s'applique le droit de retrait il
se trouve que je j'ai personnellement
mais je ne suis pas du tout un
spécialiste mais j'ai personnellement du
mal à comprendre comment alors que
l'accident intervient dans un contexte
particulier sur un type de train
particulier des conducteurs d'autres des
conducteurs d'autres matériels à
d'autres endroits pourraient considérer
que le même problème est susceptible de
se poser à eux j'ai beaucoup de mal à
comprendre pourquoi les conducteurs de
we go les conducteurs de tgv ont estimé
que sur leur ligne les mêmes sujets se
pose et or vous savez parfaitement
madame la présidente
et ça c'est du droit que certes c'est un
droit individuel que certes c'est un
droit individuel qui peut être exercée
de façon collective
monsieur le sénateur j'essaie de
répondre avec passion c'est vrai mais
dignement à madame la présidente
parler quand même donc pourquoi un
président pardon pourquoi un président
qu'est ce que vous me faites dire
pourquoi elle qu'un conducteur de tgv ou
de we go aurait dit qu'il y aurait pour
lui ou pour les passagers une menace
grave et immédiate
alors que la question qui était posée
concernés des lignes qui n'étaient pas
affectés aux grandes vitesses et qui
intéressait exclusivement les
conducteurs de ter
madame madame la présidente mon analyse
celle de la direction de la sncf
c'est que à ce moment là précis dans le
contexte de l'entreprise
quelque chose qui relève du détournement
du droit de retrait a été effectué et si
ce détournement du droit de retrait est
utilisé pour ne pas respecter les
obligations d'information en matière de
grève dans les services publics alors en
effet c'est inacceptable et c'est les
mots que j'ai employé parce que cela
fait peser sur les usagers sur
l'ensemble de notre pays sur les
familles des contraintes qui ne sont pas
acceptables
c'est ce que j'ai dit je le dis
calmement je le dis sans rien mais
connaître des obligations de sécurité et
des impératifs de sécurité
mais je le dis clairement aussi parce
que nous ne pouvons pas accepter que ce
droit individuel de retrait qui existe
et que je respecte
soit détournée de son objet pour
produire un désordre maximale lequel
vous le savez comme moi peut être
interprété de très différentes façons
dans le contexte de l'entreprise et même
dans le contexte de discussions dans
lesquelles les organisations syndicales
ont des positions à faire valoir
vous le savez comme moi c'est ça que je
voulais vous dire aujourd'hui en
redisant ici que les questions de
sécurité sont essentiels et que nous
partageons cet impératif
la parole est à notre collègue marc
laménie pour le groupe l'est républicain
cet accident met en lumière
malheureusement des dysfonctionnements
des difficultés récurrentes
d'organisation de la sncf retards
réguliers mécontentement des usagers
mais aussi des agents qui va croissant
par ailleurs la prise en otages des
passagers n'est pas forcément la
meilleure solution
la sncf fonctionne mal les raisons sont
multiples et la réforme
malheureusement ni rien changé
et madame la ministre l'administration
de votre collègue manon pénicaud mini du
travail recommande à la sncf de
suspendre le dispositif agents seule la
disparition des contrôleurs et des
moyens humains n'est pas la bonne
solution nous aimerions connaître votre
position et dames la mise quels moyens
sont mis en place pour lutter contre la
fraude dans les trains dépourvus de
contrôleurs c'est cet accident rappelle
également la dangerosité des passages à
niveau où en sommes-nous madame la
ministre dans l'exécution programme
national de sécurisation des passages à
niveau qui avait fait l'objet d'une
opération de communication de votre part
il ya quelques mois
merci d'écouter d'entendre les élus de
proximité les usagers les cheminots sur
le terrain merci pour revenir aux
conduites aux équipements agent seul je
voudrais rappeler que c'est un
dispositif qui existe depuis 40 ans en
ile de france depuis près d'une dizaine
d'années en région et qui a notamment
pour objectif de permettre aux
contrôleurs d'intervenir non pas seul
dans un train mais plutôt en équipe
ce qui est aussi bénéfique à leur propre
sécurité
je note au passage qu effectivement une
inspectrice du travail a envoyé une
lettre de recommandation à la direction
de la sncf la direction générale du
travail a eu l'occasion de dire qu'elle
ne partageait pas cette analyse
mais au delà au dollar moi j'ai constaté
que des circulation avait été
interrompue sur des tgv sur des trains
de nuit qui à ma connaissance ne sont
pas équipés agents semaine à la
présidente assassi sur des corail
intercités ce qui relie paris a
clairement paris à l'image donc je pense
que dans ces conditions on peut se dire
qu'on était bien loin du droit de
retrait donc nous sommes tous attachés
ici à la sécurité ferroviaire au respect
du droit de grève
comme nous sommes tous attachés au
service public cela veut dire aussi
penser aux usagers
la parole est notre collègue emmanuel
capus pour le groupe les indépendants
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre avec les syndicats du
ferroviaire vous l'avez compris un abus
de droit peut en cacher un autre
droit de grève ou droit de retrait tous
les moyens sont bons
nous avions déjà connu en 2018 la grève
perlée la grève capilotractée des
jusqu'au boutistes nouvel épisode même
saga nouvelle recette même tambouille
mercredi dernier un accident à un
passage à niveau a fait onze blessés
dans les ardennes dont le mécanicien
seul agent sncf à bord
cet accident a été particulièrement
violent et on ne peut remettre en
question l'émotion légitime qu'il a
suscité l'accident a fait l'objet de
plusieurs enquêtes
il faudra notamment déterminer pourquoi
le système radio sol train n'a pas
fonctionné quoi qu'il en soit force est
de constater que le droit de retrait n'a
pas été limitée à certains matériels
identifié comme éventuellement porter de
failles de sécurité
certains systèmes étaient déjà utilisés
dans les années 70 il n'a pas non plus
madame assassi était limitée aux lignes
sans contrôleur
les tgv et les intercités ou aussi était
impacté ce droit de retrait a été
étendue à tout le territoire national
la spontanéité de l'émotion a
manifestement été exploités et récupérer
les syndicats espéraient peut-être la
sympathie des usagers savants calculs
les centaines de milliers de voyageurs
bloqués lors d'un week-end de départs en
grands vents grande vague en vacances
sont évidemment excédé ou bien
s'agissait-il d'un test pour le 5
décembre
vous savez ce jour où ils vont protester
contre une réforme dont le contenu n'est
pas encore connue
la confusion des demandes mêlé à une
disproportion totale démontrent l'abus
du droit de retrait le danger grave et
imminent a semble-t-il d'ailleurs
disparu car le travail a repris sans
qu'on puisse savoir ce qui a changé
depuis mercredi dernier c'est le
caractère inique de ce mouvement
madame la ministre la question est donc
très simple pouvez-vous nous assurer que
ces dérives inacceptables seront
sanctionnés afin que le droit de retrait
ne devienne pas la façon commode de
détourner la grève
pour vous répondre madame board qui a
deux minutes parce que nous devons tenir
le temps monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur emmanuel capus comme beaucoup
de français j'ai trouvé choquant la
grève surprise qui a mis en difficulté
beaucoup de nos concitoyens
les français ont besoin du train pour se
rendre au travail ou comme le week-end
dernier
comme le week-end dernier pour partir en
vacances
et quand on dit défendre le service
public on doit d'abord penser aux
usagers alors look la grève est un droit
que personne ne remet en question mais
il existe des procédures qui permettent
aux salariés de faire valoir leurs
revendications et d'exercer leurs droits
en minimisant la gêne pour les usagers
clairement ces procédures n'ont pas été
respectées
le trafic est aujourd'hui revenue à la
normale à l'exception des ardennes et
des départements voisins et c'était
notre objectif principal
la sncf a annoncé des mesures
exceptionnelles pour indemniser les
voyageurs que ce soit le remboursement
exceptionnel des billets ou la mise en
place d'un fonds pour couvrir les frais
engagés par certains usagers mais je ne
confonds pas la méthode de cette grève
et les questions soulevées et je
voudrais redire que la sécurité c'est la
première des priorités pour tout le
monde et pas seulement pour les
syndicats c'est le sens des enquêtes qui
ont été lancés au sein de la sncf de
l'enquète qu'avec jean baptiste djebbari
nous avons demandé au bureau d'enquêté
accident dans les transports terrestres
c'est également le sens des engagements
qui ont été immédiatement pris par la
sncf
donc vous voyez monsieur le sénateur
nous sommes au travail avec la direction
pour apporter les bonnes réponses et
pour dire aussi avec fermeté que le
droit des usagers à se déplacer doit
être respecté la parole et à notre
collègue daniel grémillet pour le groupe
l'est républicain
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre le président de la république
le 11 octobre 2010 est déclaré les états
généraux de l'alimentation aux deux
objectifs le premier permettre aux
agriculteurs de vivre du ce prix payé de
permettre à tous dans la chaîne de
valeur de vivre dignement et le second
de permettre à chacune et à chacun
d'avoir accès à une alimentation saine
durable et sûre il déclarait aussi il
est plus possible qu'aujourd'hui en
france un tiers des adducteurs gagnent
moins de 350 euros par an et aujourd'hui
où en sommes-nous
vous nous avez fait par mois par dont
vous nous avez fait naître beaucoup
d'espoirs vous nous avez parlé la montée
en gamme
la seule montée en gamme qu'ont vu les
agriculteurs ce sont des contraintes
supplémentaires
ce sont des charges supplémentaires ce
sont 80 intrusion dans des élevages
démontrant la maltraitance des animaux
et jamais on a vu une vidéo montrant un
agriculteur pleurer devant un animal qui
me lève de périr ce qu'on leur fait
croire dans cette montée en gamme
c'est aussi les accords du méco
ressoures les accords du ceta voyez ce
ministre il y avait beaucoup d'attentes
et beaucoup d'espoirs vous l'avez vous
même déclaré cette semaine parce que
cette montée en gamme
rien n'est arrivé chez agriculteurs vous
avez dit les acteurs n'ont pas eu le
fruit de cette loi les galim calé vous
répondre aux agriculteurs à qui vous
avez fait naître autant d'espoir pour
nous répondre
la parole est à mme sioniste
d'agriculture de l'alimentation merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur de la grille et je partage
votre inquiétude et vous dire que le
gouvernement et moi-même sont tout
entier derrière les agriculteurs lorsque
ceux ci sont montrés du doigt lorsque
ceux ci sont insultés
lorsque ceux ci sont violentés lorsque
les délais des élevages sont des
bâtiments d'élevage sont brûlés c'est
inacceptable
la garde des sceaux est intervenue avait
écrit une instruction à tous les atouts
les procureurs c'est inacceptable et
cela doit s'arrêter sur la deuxième
partie de votre question sur les états
généraux
je crois que les états généraux ont
soulevé un espoir immense un espoir
immense qui c'est qui s'est conclue
conclue par une décision unanime de
l'ensemble du monde agricole des
industries agroalimentaires des
entreprises de transformation des
coopératives et de d1 des responsables
politiques pour dire qu'il fallait
changer la façon de faire est la
première chose qu'il fallait changer
c'était le prix payé aux agriculteurs il
est absolument inacceptable qu'un
agriculteur ventes sont les ventes sa
viande en dessous du prix de revient
en dessous de ce que ça lui de ce que ça
lui repas et vous savez c'est pas c'est
pas en criant que vous ferez augmenter
le prix du lait ou le prix de la viande
mais c'est comme je le fais depuis le
depuis lundi en rencontrant toutes les
filières et encore jusqu'à ce matin et
toutes les filières sont dans les mêmes
conditions
ils veulent tous que le coût de
production qu'ils ont eux mêmes fixé
soit respecté mais c'est pas le
gouvernement qu'il fait respecter c'est
le marché c'est je suis désolé ce sens
ce sont les coopératives cachette de le
lait c'est pas le gouvernement
ce sont les la grande distribution qui
achètent des produits ce n'est pas le
gouvernement
et c'est la raison pour laquelle nous en
sommes nous en sommes nous en sommes à
plus de 3000 contrôles de la dgccrf
il a reste 2000 à faire
nous prendre encore plus de sanctions
s'il le faut il faut que la grande
distribution et les entreprises
respectent les agriculteurs et achète le
prix là où le prix que ça correspond
jour merci monsieur grémillet monsieur
le ministre je reprends la conclusion du
président de la république qui disait ce
que j'attends de vous pour finir c'est
de recréer la confiance savez monsieur
le ministre en agriculture il pousse
toujours quelque chose
et lorsqu'on sème le vent récolte la
tempête
et aujourd'hui ça a été exprimée par les
agriculteurs hier hélas il y en a 300
compas pu manifester et monsieur le
ministre
faut pas mentir aux agriculteurs il faut
pas tromper la société parce que
aujourd'hui d'aujourd'hui va dépendre ce
qui aura dans laser assiettes de nos
enfants demain la parole elle dans notre
collègue nathalie delattre pour le
groupe du rassemblement démocratique et
social européen
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre l'organe de règlement
des différends de l'om sait a confirmé
la semaine dernière autorisé les états
unis à augmenter les taxes sur les biens
et les services européens dans le cadre
du dossier des subventions airbus le
président trump a choisi de réserver un
traitement de faveur au deuxième poste
excédentaire de 11,7 milliards d'euros
de notre balance commerciale française
le vin les droits de douane sont
désormais en hausse de 25% pour les vins
dits tranquilles 25% sur un marché qui
dépasse les trois milliards par an
conquis par des années de ténacité
tandis que les américains ont stoppé eux
en quasi une seconde
nos exportations la viticulture
française est aujourd'hui la victime
collatérale d'un conflit industriel qui
ne la concerne pas une nouvelle épreuve
pour une filière entrer dans une forte
zone de turbulences à l'étranger nos
marchés sont moroses instabilité
politique à hong kong obligeant
l'annulation du wine festival
interminable break site écroulement du
marché chinois où il ya cinq ans la
viticulture faisait déjà les frais d'un
conflit avec l'union européenne
sur les panneaux photovoltaïques un
contexte national en berne également
attaqué de toutes parts sur ses propres
terres par l'urbanisation rampante par
la pression sociétale sur
l'environnement et la traçabilité des
produits mais aussi par la raréfaction
de la main d'oeuvre et les
problématiques de transmission le modèle
viticole français est sérieusement
ébranlé le vitib aching fait son oeuvre
et sapent le moral des vignerons une
filière qui fait tant d'efforts
malgré les déchaînements climatiques et
concours largement à ce que la france
soit pour la troisième année consécutive
considéré comme ayant l'alimentation la
plus durable du monde
que faire monsieur le premier ministre
pour le vin qui occupe une place
particulière dans la culture française
ainsi que dans notre économie puisque ce
sont plus de 500 mille emplois directs
et indirects
les élus du vin et des terroirs
regroupés en associations dont je suis
la coprésidente vous en proposer il y a
quelques semaines l'organisation en
urgence d'un grenelle de la viticulture
allez-vous y répondre par l'affirmative
je vous remercie
merci pour vous répondre la parole est
qu'à madame la secrétaire d'état auprès
de la milice des armes et madame
darrieussecq au pardon
non j'ai confondu avec le bizz'art
militaire la réponse est à didier
guillot ministre de l'agriculture et de
l'alimentation voilà bon j'ai pas trop
mal sorti comme un moyen président il ne
s'agit que du vin mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs madame la sénatrice amélie
de montchanin a répondu avant sur la
situation globale concernant l'ensemble
des filières suite à la question du
sénateur young qui ont été moi donc de
répondre particulièrement sur votre
question concernant le vin français et
vous dire que comme l'a fait la suède à
l'état le gouvernement est tout entier
mobilisé
bruno le maire est et à washington il ya
encore quelques heures pour essayer de
faire bouger ce qui va être difficile au
sahb le mans la position des amériques
ce que nous ne souhaitons pas c'est
attendre les six mois de délai pour que
dans six mois la france met à son tour
d'autres sanctions parce que ce serait
la course à l'échalote et ce ne serait
pas bon donc nous privilégions
évidemment les solutions de compromis
mais on n'est pas totalement sûr
qu'elles arrivent immédiatement
aussi nous avons vraiment essayé de
mobiliser à la fois la commission
européenne et des positions françaises
lors du conseil des ministres de la
culture le 14 octobre dernier au nom de
l'italie de l'espagne et de la france
sus intervenu pour demander la
solidarité des états membres est
intervenu pour demander à phil hogan le
commissaire à l'agriculture qu'un cran
là pour quelques jours que l'europe
prenne des décisions
il faut absolument prenez prendre des
décisions fortes un premièrement d une
décision de solidarité européenne
deuxièmement des décisions dead au
maintien économique et troisièmement des
décisions dead pour aller chercher de
nouveaux marchés
parce que si ce n'est pas le cas il y
aura de grosses difficultés dans la
filière viticole
c'est aujourd'hui toutes les régions qui
sont touchés c'est sur les vins d'entrée
de gamme et de et de volume et ses plus
de 300 millions d'euros dont il s'agit
s'il n'y avait pas quelque chose pour
compenser je pense que la filière
viticole comme vous le disait justement
quelques difficultés auraient du mal un
ca à s'en relever aussi aujourd'hui j'ai
envoyé un nouveau courrier au
commissaire européen pour lui demandé
trois choses que la commission finance
la mise en oeuvre rapide des programmes
de promotion
c'est absolument indispensable que des
garanties soient apportées aux
opérateurs
mettant en oeuvre ces mêmes mesures
parce qu'aujourd'hui les opérateurs sont
sûres sont sur la brèche et enfin que la
solidarité européenne viennent par
rapport à l'om c'est j'ai reçu hier
l'ensemble de la filière viticole ils
ont des propositions à faire
nous sommes en train de l'est de les
regarder pour savoir comment nous
pourrions avancer je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à notre collègue richard yom pour le
groupe de la république en marche
n'avait la parole mon cher collègue
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur trump vendredi dernier à
imposer de nouvelles sanctions
douanières contre des produits
d'exportation venant d'europe
il y en a pour 7 milliards et demi dont
1 milliard pour la france
ceci fait suite à une décision de l'om
c'est relatives au financement des
développements d'airbus permettez-moi
trois remarques
la première c'est que les états unis
n'accorde aucune estime à l'om c'est ils
ont même cherché à la démolir ils ont
refusé de nommer les juges et les
curieux de voir que soudain pris par la
vertu ils accordent la plus le plus
grand enthousiasme et la plus grande
célérité à l'application des décisions
de l'om 7
les etats unis imposent leur législation
économique et financière à travers le
monde à tous les pays
l'exemple de l'iran est dans tous les
esprits et il faut dire que en tant
qu'europe nous répondons relativement
mollement enfin à ma connaissance le
gouvernement fédéral américain déversent
des centaines de milliards de dollars
dans l'industrie aéronautique américaine
sous prétexte de contrat d'études et de
recherches pour la france sont concernés
par ces sanctions les avions les avions
fini bon il ya des avions non finie mais
là il ya des avions fini + 10 % les vins
tranquilles
donc le champagne n'est pas concerné
ainsi que le vouvray donc je m'en
réjouis
et les fromages nous ne pouvons que
refuser que regrettait le refus de
négocier des états unis et dans ce cet
affrontement bilatérales s'étaient bien
sûr le jeu de la chine que je me joue
monsieur 30 sans doute aurons-nous à
prendre des mesures de sauvegarde ou de
compensation pour les exportateurs
français peut-être pouvez-vous nous en
dire un mot
l' omc devrait donner la possibilité à
l'europe d'imposer des sanctions aux
rockeurs going en 2020 mais je crains
que cela soit trop tard j'espère et vous
pouvez peut-être leur assurer là dessus
allez l'europe prendra des mesures bien
avant 2020
madame la ministre recherche des
affaires européennes
merci monsieur le président monsieur
sénateurs young effectivement comme vous
l'avez décrit les droits de douane
additionnels qui ont été décidées par
les états unis font suite à une décision
rendue par l'om c'est dans le cadre d'un
contentieux engagé en 2004 c'est-à-dire
il ya plus de 15 ans et donc ses droits
que vous l'avez rappelé ce sont 7 5
milliards de dollars d'importations
européenne parents qui concerne vous
l'avez dit l'aéronautique l'agriculture
la viticulture
le gouvernement est pleinement mobilisé
que ce soit jean baptiste maunier
guillaume bruno le maire est également
la présence plus que symbolique de la
chancelière merkel et du président la
république
chez airbus mercredi dernier pour un
conseil des ministres franco allemand
qui visaient notamment rappelé
l'importance européenne que nous
apportons ensemble et le soutien que
nous apportons notamment à airbus
l'union européenne vous l'avez dit ce
serait fondée à imposer des droits de
douane contre les états unis dans le
contentieux parallèle contre boeing
mais le calendrier vous l'avez dit n'est
pas très favorable puisque nous
attendons les confirmations de l'om
c'est des montants que nous pourrions
imposé et que nous le connaîtrons
qu'avant quelques mois et pas avant
probablement en 2020
notre préférence va à une résolution à
l'amiable de ces contentieux car nous
pensons que l'escaladé des tensions nées
avec un allié et un partenaire n'est pas
souhaitable puisque ça aurait un impact
encore plus négatif sur nos économistes
notre commerce et sur notre industrie
aéronautique
nous continuons donc à proposer aux
états unis de dialoguer nous avons été
l'union européenne et des états unis
tous deux condamnés dans cette affaire
vieille de plus de 15 ans
et nous pensons que d'imposer des droits
de douane nous devrions travailler
ensemble à un compromis équilibré pour
mieux encadrer les futures subventions
aéronautique
puisque nous savons que en chine l'état
lui ne se prive pas de subventionner
massivement ses propres constructeur est
donc de renforcer ses positions et c'est
à eux au fond que cette affaire
bénéficient et c'est bien là tout le
paradoxe
nous regrettons que jusqu'ici les états
unis aient refusé d'engager les
discussions vers un compromis
j'appelle ici devant vous très
solennellement l'administration
américaine a entamé des négociations le
plus vite possible sans quoi nous
prendrons des mesures de rétorsion et
d'ici là et didier guillaume a pu
mobiliser lors du dernier conseil des
ministres à bruxelles la commission
européenne pour que nous puissions
protéger les viticulteurs les
agriculteurs les plus impactés par des
mesures de savon très ciblée je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]